la une pour cette semaine a été dévoilée
elle fait beaucoup parler regarder on y
voit à anne hidalgo la merde pas à côté
de coutume le couteau qui sont posées
dans des appareils qui ressemble à ceux
des vélib parisien charlie hebdo
présente d'ailleurs cette invention
comme les couteaux libre et ils disent
même
enfin quelque chose qui fonctionne à
paris alors bien sûr c'est pas les unes
charlie hebdo et font souvent polémique
vous vous aimez vous vous n'aimez pas
c'est parti une minute trente pour que
vous aimez gilles j'aime cette une qui
mêle deux actualités dont une est
dramatique mais parce que c'est charlie
charlie qui a été meurtri dans sa chair
charlie qui s'en est sorti toujours par
l'humour par le rire et ne pas aimer
cette une
benjamin castaldi c'est ne plus être
charlie va écouter plus j'allais moi ça
me fait rire d'abord un pourquoi la
maire de paris sur la couverture
deuxièmement l'événement il a à peine à
peine trois jours mais d'accord et puis
côté couteau ni ben franchement cette
fois-ci mois sera pas fait rire autant
j'étais saoul toujours trouvé ça plutôt
marrant pas toujours mais voilà
globalement il y avait un droit la
caricature ils ont fait des unes après
le massage de charlie il est en fait
beaucoup plus tard évidemment et pour
cause mais là c'est trop tôt c'est pas
drôle
essayez eu quand même un mort quatre
blessés et bois se met pas rire voilà
excusez-moi couteau litres n'est pas
drôle du tout mais qui est né au canada
avait besoin évident
vous avez fait vous n'avez que quelques
à la cheville mais vous êtes petit vin
de manager laenser vous êtes le
régisseur du rire mais n'avait aucun
droit dessus du régime des mollahs
je ne censure pas avec le temps à
préparer vous la plus chère les cas cela
dit oser le dire
vos dépenses est une là je suis pas
charrier du tout non pas c'est une honte
tout ça c'est que ça n'a pas l'air
dépasse confie laisse finir les deux et
après examen
moi je vous dis pas gd soutenu ça a été
sous le nom fait beaucoup rire là c'est
trop tôt c'est malvenu c'est pas bien
voilà c'est tout moi si l'on pense à la
une quelle lâcheté tu leur est faite
celle-là non eh ben voilà j'aime charlie
pour tout ce qu'ils sont et pour cette
une
aussi dans les voiles à faire le tour de
table un match d'hommes au kivu
alors moi autant à l inverse les
caricatures n'avait pas fait rire du
tout pourquoi parce qu'elle mettait en
danger d'autres personnes à mon sens et
on s'en est rendu compte
là en revanche c'est une j'aime beaucoup
pas parce qu'elle est drôle comme tu dis
c'est pas l'humour du charlie que j'aime
moi c'est pas cet humour là que j'aime
mais en revanche parce que là il
dénombre trois mois quelque chose
ils dénoncent le fait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya un véritable problème est qu'on ne
sait pas comment le régler et qui a de
plus en plus de violence n'est donc moi
en revanche je trouvais ça très très
bien c'est une princesse erika non mais
moi j'aimerais dire que surtout elle est
elle prête un peu à confusion parce que
si tu vois pas la légende un peu
l'impression que ce sont des douanes ont
ou pas regardes tu regardes bien cyrille
regard oui oui t'as pas l'impression que
ce sont des des des objets que j'ai
rigolé au départ et à vous avez passé je
n'ai pas vu dans cete d'aidé d'écouté
alors qu'ils estiment vous voilà d'où
vous voulez c'est drôle non
donc ne me plaît pas je comprends les
arguments de gilles parce qu'on est à un
moment on a été tous charlie mais moi
effectivement c'est un peu frais même si
c'est un défi pour charlie qui ont été
meurtris dans leur chair par le par le
terrorisme de se relever par cette forme
d'humour et par le terrorisme n'est pas
l'humour sur le terrorisme je trouve ça
mal venu
moi je me pose même pas la question de
savoir si c'est drôle parole j'ai pas
envie de rire de ce genre de choses
c'est tout don d'organes et n'ont même
pas si c'est drôle j'ai peur de rien il
y avait un mort qui va dans la rue
voilà qui aurait pu y en avoir beaucoup
plus gérable mais de rire on n'a pas
expliqué le rire on n'a pas expliqué
d'humour on n'a pas expliqué ça n'a pas
à faire l'unanimité
donc on s'en fout que ce soit évidemment
c'est trash c'est au vitriol
c'est même ma maison moi ça me fait rire
autant que ça me ça me glace en fait et
je trouve que c'est totalement réussi
jean-luc moi je pense qu'ils sont dans
leurs fonctions charlie y dénonce des
choses ils sont limite et en même temps
ils m'ont dérangé quand à sa couille ça
ils s'attaquaient aux victimes comme en
italie ou comme johnny hallyday comme
c'est de l'électro l'âge tant qu'ils ont
leurs fonctions et son bien par contre
qu'est ce que ça m'agace quand je lis tu
dis quand il a plus d'arguments nous
sommes charlie mais vous n'êtes plus
charlie comme c'était une insulte de nos
pieds de charlie et c'est l'argument
massue être charlie c'est aussi avoir
l'esprit critique donc ta voix que
redouté des véhicules moi je suis pas
charlie cette ligne ne m'a pas déplu à
aller on va regarder tiendra qui vous a
plus convaincu benjamin castaldi à 71%
gilles amat 9% donc cette fugue n'a pas
plu à nos téléspectateurs